Hey youtubers it's Charlie and in case you
did not hear a copy of The first episode of
The Flash TV Show leaked online.
I'm not going to allow anyone to share it
here and I'm not going to do spoilers.
But I will explain what happened and what
the CW might end up doing about it.
As in post it early on their website.
The same thing happened to a bunch of Legend
of Korra Book 3 episodes last week.
That was way worse because it was 4 episodes
instead of just one and they weren't even
the first 4.
Which means if people watched them, they missed
a giant chunk of the story.
Hello to all you new people, if you're finding
me for the first time I'm going to be doing
bonus videos for The Flash and Arrow all summer.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'll be doing weekly episode videos too once
the new seasons start in October.
For those who are wondering, they'll probably
start season 3 of Arrow and Season 1 of the
Flash around the same time Arrow Season 2
started last year.
Which was the first week in October.
So WTF is up with the leak.
Whenever networks want critics at big news
organizations to cover their shows they usually
send out screener DVDs, they have a watermark
on them with some disclosure language about
not reselling or posting them anywhere.
They're not meant for the public.
The CW has been sending out copies of the
first episode of The Flash and one of those
is what leaked online.
Or someone yoinked it off someone else's desk
and uploaded it.
I actually work for a couple big news organizations
in real life.
I know everyone always asks what I do in real
life.
I actually do youtube stuff like this for
a couple big trade websites.
So we get piles and piles of screeners for
everything you've ever heard of and a ton
of stuff that will probably never make it
to air.
So when you send thousands of copies of a
dvd all over creation, it's not hard to figure
out why someone would steal a copy and upload
it to the internet.
The other possibility is that The CW intentionally
leaked the episode.
Networks have done that in the past, as a
way to drive interest in something.
It usually only works when it's comic book
related or associated with a major fandom.
Like if a copy of Star Wars Episode 7 leaked,
all of creation would flip.
The CW isn't really known for leaking their
own material as a way to generate viral interest,
and since The Flash TV Show already has really
good buzz, the wouldn't need to do that anyway
.So my first theory is probably the right
one, someone stole a copy and uploaded it.
What is the CW going to do about it?
Usually as a means of diffusing the situation,
tv networks will just post the episode online.
Whenever those Korra episodes leaked though,
Nickelodeon decided to start airing episodes
on television months in advance of their original
release date.
Because it was only the first episode of The
Flash to leak and The CW just did upfronts
they're probably not going to air the season
early.
At upfronts usually deals are made between
advertisers and networks where they buy advertising
on episodes of The Flash during a certain
time of the year.
So if the CW ran episodes early, they would
lose millions of dollars in advertising.
So you're still going to have to wait till
October for the season to start.
But they could still totally post the full
episode on their website and stream it for
free as a way to control the situation.
They haven't made an official announcement
yet.
Originally they would have just aired the
episode at Comic Con and then maybe posted
it online the next week.
So it still would have aired before the fall.
If you were one of the people who watched
it, please use spoiler tags when talking about
the plot.
If you've read any of the Flash origin stories,
you already know what the story is anyway,
they never do things exactly like they are
in the comics.
Arrow for instance, changes a lot of character
backstories and has created a lot of new original
characters.
If you do want to read a very close version
of the story they're doing in the flash tv
show.
Read Flash Rebirth, it was written by Geoff
Johns, one of the writers on The Flash TV
Show.
There are a lot of small differences, but
thematically it's the same idea.
Geoff Johns has been one of my favorite DC
Comics writers of the last 20 years.
Oh, and he's also an executive producer on
the Batman vs Superman movie.
Right now he's writing the new Superman series
drawn by John Romita Jr., he's the guy who
drew Kick Ass which is why it looks so similar.
A very Kick Ass Superman.
If you want to learn more about what their
version of Superman is going to be like I'll
post a link to a huge article the New York
Times wrote about them.
If you haven't seen any of them, the CW has
been posting a lot of new interviews and footage
from The Flash.
Mostly filling in a lot of the expanded universe
of Central City.
Like what's going on with Star Labs and all
the metahumans that were created when the
particle accelerator exploded.
I've actually been talking about this all
year in my Arrow videos, so please let me
know if you subscribed recently or you haven't
seen any of my Arrow stuff.
I've got a giant playlist that I'll add a
link in the description for.
The summer is the best time to catch up on
Arrow.
Even though they're two different groups of
people making those shows, they will exist
in a shared universe.
We even saw Stephen Amell in the Flash trailer.
So watching both shows will increase your
enjoyment.
The fun thing about Flash that's really different
from Arrow is that they're going all in on
superpowers.
If you've seen the trailer you know Weather
Wizard is the first Rogue we meet.
I don't count Zoom as a Rogue.
They're definitely not trying to hide the
Zoom or Reverse Flash character either.
He's been such a huge part of the comics for
so long, there's no point.
And even though Edward Thawne is at the police
station, they're not really saying he's Zoom
either.
So he'll be present at all times, like an
over arching story while week to week Barry
tracks down rogues and other metahumans.
The one big change is the Harrison Wells character
that Tom Cavanagh is playing.
In the canon, the founder of star labs was
named Garrison Slate.
That character was featured in a lot of Blue
Beetle Comics.
Because Arrow is introducing Blue Beetle this
year we might get to see some Star Labs Kord
Industries overlapping stories.
Blue Beetle hasn't been officially confirmed,
but Arrow put out a casting call for someone
bearing the name of the Golden Age Blue Beetle.
Which is a dead giveaway.
Although when Arrow brings him on, just like
Barry Allen, Ted Kord will probably be a pre-blue
beetle Ted Kord or it will be like a Batman
Year One situation where he's still figuring
everything out.
I know a lot of people have been reporting
Gorilla Grodd easter eggs in the flash footage.
It sounds like The Flash is going to do a
planet of the apes situation whereby Gorilla
Grodd attains his super intelligence through
the same dimensional rift that was caused
by the particle accelerator explosion.
I don't expect him to come on the show anytime
soon, but don't be surprised if you see more
references to him.
Aside from the rogues and Zoom, Gorilla Grodd
is one of the most infamous Flash Villains.
Which is funny, because rise of the planet
of the apes is coming out really soon.
So because of Vidcon this week my schedule
is a little weird, but I'm still going to
try and post a bonus Arrow video before I
go, I am doing a special personal Q&A, so
feel free to ask me any personal questions
you want in addition to Flash and Arrow stuff.
Remember, if you have seen the leaked footage,
please use spoiler tags in the comments for
those that want to wait.
Right now click here to learn all about Blue
Beetle and the Batman villains Arrow is doing
in season 3 and click here for my breakdown
of the Flash Trailer.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!